عدد ضحايا زلزال تركيا وسوريا يتجاوز 5000
اردوغان يعلن حاله الطوارئ في المناطق
المنكوبه ولاده رضيعه تحت الانقاذ في
سوريا هذه الاخبار وغيرها ننقلها لكم من
قناه العربيه فهلا بكم
[موسيقى]
مع استمرار الاعداد بالتزايد تخطى مجمل
عدد الضحايا الذين سقطوا جراء الزلزال في
تركيا وسوريا 5000 قتيل واكثر من 24 الف
جريح في تركيا وحدها تجاوز عدد القتلى قتل
الزلزال 3700 شخص والجرحى 22 الفا في
مقاله وزاره الصحه في النظام السوري ان
عدد الضحايا ارتفع الى 1622 قتيلا و 1449
مصابا في كل من حلب والادقيه وحماه وريف
ادلب وترطوس اما الدفاع المدني التابع
للمعارضه فاعلن ان عدد الضحايا في شمال
غرب سوريا ارتفع الى اكثر من 810 قتلى
واكثر من 22
في كلمه توجه بها الى شعبه اعلن رئيس
التركي رجب طيب اردوغان حلقه الطوارئ في
المناطق المنكوبه لمده ثلاثه اشهر وتخصيص
خمسه مليارات دولار كخطوه اولى لاسترجاع
الخدمات الاساسيه السريعا في تلك المناطق
اردوغان اعتبر ان زلزال من اسوا الكوارث
الطبيعيه التي تعرضت لها تركيا في التاريخ
لافتا الى ان بلاده تلقت عروض مساعده من
اكثر من 70 دوله و14 منظمه
الزلزال المدمر الذي شغل الجميع في شمال
غرب سوريا استغله بعض السجناء للفرار من
سجن راجو الذي يقع تحت سيطره فصائل سوريا
مواليه لتركيا ويحتجز فيه نحو الفيسجين
غالبيتهم يشتبه بانتمائهم نحو 20 سجنا
تمكنوا من الهروب من هذا السجن الذي تاثر
بالزلزال فيما قال مسؤولون ان السجن شهد
مساء الاثنين عصيا
السجناء من السيطره على عدد من اقسام
السجن
في مشهد اشبه بالمعجزه تمكنت فرق الانقاذ
في بلده جنديرس شمال سوريا من انتشار
الرضيعه على قيد الحياه ولدت تحت الانقال
الصغيره بقيت متصله عبر الحبه السري
بوالدتها التي توفيت مباشره بعد ولادتها
هي وجميع افراد عائلتها فيما تتلقى
الرضيعه حاليا العنايه الطبيه في احدى
مستشفيات عفرين المجاوره باقصى شمال
محافظه حلب
نختم من مدينه اسكندرون بولايه هاتاي جنوب
تركيا التي شهدت ازمه جديده بعد ساعه من
تعرض البلاد للزلزال المدمر الزلزال تسبب
في ارتفاع منسوب البحر ما ادى الى دخول
المياه في شوارع المدينه المطله على
الساحل والذي تسبب بدوره بتشكل بوراكميه
بطول 200 متر في بعض المناطق نتج عنها
ازمات مروريه بحسب ما نقلت وسائل اعلام
تركيا
[موسيقى]